[Musique]
bienvenue dans cette page était cette
semaine on va parler de graffitis écrire
et dessiner sur les murs la pratique qui
n'est pas récente elle remonte à la
préhistoire
mais le graffiti au tournant des années
70-80 devient une des disciplines de la
culture hip hop qui né aux états unis où
discipline qu'il a traversé l'atlantique
et se développer en france d'abord à
paris mais aussi dans notre région
durant quatre jours nous allons visiter
des lieux du graffiti à orléans et à
tours et rencontrer des acteurs et
passionnés de ce mouvement
pour notre premier reportage nous sommes
allés à la rencontre de robert mal
nourris ce septuagénaire photographier
les murs de sa ville depuis plus de 30
ans et il est devenu un peu la mémoire
du graffiti orléanais tout a commencé
ici dans le quartier de la vinaigrerie
des sceaux il ya plus de trente ans
photographe à l'inventaire du patrimoine
robert malnoury prend ses premiers
clichés de graffitis et des vieux murs
partout et cette découverte de tags
jusque dans le bas de la tour
ça commence à faire est un événement aux
états unis est assez important donc je
me suis dit tiens ça va arriver chez
nous sur les murs des bâtiments
désaffectés fleurissent inscription et
dessins de la mode des pochoirs au
développement des lettrages il
immortalise l'évolution d'une culture
aux oeuvres souvent éphémère sur des
murs qui ont vu défiler des générations
d'artistes et d'admirateurs cette flore
hyper hyper changeant ça ouais c'est si
on vient ici réd une fois tous les deux
ou trois semaines on n'en verra jamais
un chose donc c'est c'est toujours un
moment un lieu assez assez sympa venir
way en quelques décennies sur pellicule
puis supports numériques robert malnoury
accumule des milliers d'image désormais
retraité il les partage sur les réseaux
sociaux et continue de photographier
sans discriminer donc je travaille à
l'inventaire fait on ferait un
inventaire systématique des choses que
tu es anciennes ou intéressante
et puis j'ai un peu cet esprit là et
puis je me dis qu'un grave peut-être pas
terrible
et va progresser mais c'est dommage de
pas avoir ses premiers dessins plusieurs
fois par semaine il promène son objectif
en quête de nouveautés comme au mur du
bois joli à sarran avec le temps il
s'est familiarisé avec les lieux et les
codes des artistes leur nom de graffeurs
s'appellent des blazes le moment donné
c'est quoi ces côtes anglaises au sud de
la loire autre lieu le mur de la
passerelle entre l'hiver et la source
robert il vient depuis le début des
années 2000 l'endroit est une
institution pour les initier un terrain
c'est toujours la bonne occasion pour se
rencontrer pour discuter un peu
donc tu te pousser un peu essayé d
expérimenter d'être hub est allé un peu
plus loin il ya une gestuelle qui est
intéressant quand on le voit en france
et leur très étrange est en possession
bien sûr deux lotos au tout début
j'étais habillé en noir et une casquette
ils m'ont pris pour un script qui se
pâment aux gens des gens vont très bien
de pouvoir voir nos peintures grâce à
robert et puis en même temps il permet
de de conserver un morceau d'histoire de
ce mouvement et ça ça n'a pas de prix
[Musique]
nous sommes toujours à orléans nous
retrouvons devant le mur un lieu
d'expression artistique ouvert depuis
quatre ans nous sommes avec l'un des
directeurs artistiques de ce lieu
ludovic bourreau ludovic comment est
venue l'idée pourquoi cette démarche
alors c'était un projet qu'on a observés
à paris
dans le 11e arrondissement de l'espace
dédié à la création contemporaine
urbaine qui est en place depuis dix ans
et donc en fait on a on a souhaité
souhaité faire comme eux en fait là vous
êtes devant la 32e fresque de mad velvet
un artiste bordelais donc dit presque
parents grosso modo la avec l'écho vide
on a un petit peu espacées on n'avait
pas trop le choix mais ça y est on est
reparti les artistes viennent
la scène graffiti d'ailleurs de quels
horizons il ya des artistes issus du
graffiti qui font encore un travail
vandal il y en a qui ont un parcours
plus classique
après un peu complexifier un petit peu
tout ça c'est à dire que certains sont
issus du graffiti mais travaille plus
avec la bombe et sont assez au pinceau
d'autant un parcours classique mais sont
passés à la bombe à ce que la bombe est
un outil avant d'être autre chose que ça
donc c'est très large programmation
était un peu contrarié quels sont les
artistes à venir au mois de septembre on
a convié olivia de bonnart qui
interviendra sur la figure de jeanne
d'arc puis ce qu'on a on nous a soumis
cette proposition on a accepté de faire
travailler une artiste sur la figure de
jeanne d'arc
voilà pour un petit peu modernisé cette
figure merci beaucoup ludovic voilà un
travail autour de jeanne d'arc pour les
fêtes johanniques reprogrammé en
septembre c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
demain nous irons à tour à demain